Gooooood
morning, John, it's Tuesdaaaaaay!
June 19th.
[singing] I'm back in the basement agaaaain.
I'm back in the basement again!
I'm mostly underground, and you can't hear a sound 'cause I'm back in the basement again!
It's comfortable here.
I made a little nest for myself
where I can nuzzle up
and come down here when it's too hot outside,
and I'm back in the basement again!
But, I don't envy you having to move out of your house,
having to leave your little studio.
I wonder what's gonna be in the background of your new videos?
Is it still gonna be your bookcase?
Or are you gonna do it somewhere else?
Maybe Brotherhood 2.0 viewers would like a change of setting every once in a while.
I mean, for a while, people were, you know,
impressed by my map of the realm of Narnia
and my floating bookshelves back there.
But now nobody talks about that anymore.
Maybe I should start filming upstairs
in my bedroom
with the cat
at the Missoula Skate park
maybe somewhere from downtown Missoula
Or from Target
You know, on location.
Not today though.
But I'd be interested if people have suggestions.
So what's the news, you ask?
Oh, let me tell you: there's news.
There's this news
You might not be impressed with this kind of stuff John anymore,
But it's still very exciting for me.
I can go to Barnes and Noble and be like,
"Hey. I wrote this. That's me."
People will gasp, "You're famous!"
Just like that:
"Famous!"
And I'll say,
"You don't know the half of it."
The other day, I was wearing my Brotherhood 2.0
In my pants shirt, and that lady came up and asked me about it.
I thought that was actually kind of brave of her?
I mean, would you go up to somebody who had a t-shirt like that?
I mean, I've seen a lot of weird t-shirts in my time
but I don't generally walk up to people ask them what they're about.
There's an idea for a project!
Asking people about their t-shirts
Gotta find someplace public with lots of t-shirts and be like,
"What the..."
"It's the future! He saw it, and it's going to crush him."
A lot of times, there's no explaining.
I mean, talking to strangers is fun right?
As long as the t-shirt doesn't say something like
"Don't talk to me about mah t-shirt
or I will put forks in you!"
That would be an amazing t-shirt!
Other news!
I was on the Weather Channel!
I mean, I knew that they had recorded me for the Weather Channel
but then suddenly, I was actually ON the Weather Channel.
I missed it, but it will be on again several times.
The show is called "Forecast Earth"
I believe
The particular episode is entitled
Something about
hotness
heat
global heat
heating up
heater or heaters
space heater
Space heater? Probably not.
It starts out, I think with John Kerry
and I'm at the very end.
But that's definitely my first national television appearance.
And I'm pretty sure that they mentioned Brotherhood 2.0!
Woo party Hank woo Hank party!
Anyhow, I talked to The Yeti this afternoon
And she and John were in the moving truck
leaving New York!
Actually, trying to get out of the city while in a moving truck.
Which I'm sure can't be very easy.
So, let us all get together
And say lucky, lucky, lucky, lucky, lucky, lucky woo!
Good luck getting out of the city and getting to Indianapolis!
Good luck moving into your new house!
Good luck doing a video tomorrow!
while moving into your new house
cause that's gonna suck.
And thanks for your video. It always sucks leaving a good place.
I hope I don't have to do it anytime soon.
I'll see you tomorrow. I hope.